[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
I'm gonna be taking a step back from
being on King in The Sting If We Had a
podcast together yeah it would take over
sorry Brandon the bike the podcast is
off it's just gonna be some Sting
I gotta go to Nashville to get away from
all this La chaos man
I don't I don't want this [ __ ] to be
[ __ ] happening what's with the trash
Tuesday beef when are we gonna settle
the trash Tuesday be just two white guys
kicking it oh yeah dude the endangered
species podcast
because we're going out of [ __ ]
business man this is this past weekend
funniest guy I know
that would be [ __ ] insane bro
actually with Brendan though is [ __ ]
crazy that was like the worst game of
Clue I'd ever seen in the world did you
try to Vlog any Letterman to your truck
no it doesn't make sense no
[ __ ] we've been doing it like four years
I don't know has it been that long
[Music]
this is this past weekend too many this
is already theovan left the King singing
Wing podcast last week leaving many
people to wonder who he's going to team
up with next if anyone why did he leave
Brendan's shop is something in the works
with Bobby Lee potentially lots of
questions surrounding Theo right now in
his future so I put in our community
section a poll asking the comedy fans
who they think theavon should team up
with next and here are the results so
over 6 000 people have voted on this
poll so far and the winner was
outstanding by a large margin Bobby Lee
I think that was expected 57 of the poll
coming in second was Andrew Schultz with
18 kristalia had 12 percent of the vote
and then brenshaw and other in comment
split at six percent Theo and Bobby need
each other especially now their banter
is second to none unless Leo moves back
to LA it would never work with Bobby
that's actually a good point with Theo
splitting his time between LA and
Nashville that's kind of the reason why
I didn't really work with the king and
the sting maybe there were other things
at play but location has to be
considered in this dude there are times
people come on take a picture like can I
get a picture with you and then like can
you try and look more like Bobby Lee in
the picture they will literally want me
to be like they're like can you squint a
little can you
can you not really yeah
can you dress like you sell time shares
at a carnival
they're like can you help me yeah yeah
do I get girls going you are the most
beloved I have girls on my DMs going
you're all right but can you introduce
me to Theo oh yeah
and it's like everywhere I go it's like
I don't know a single Bobby Lee fan that
isn't a huge theophon fan him and Bobby
could so do a podcast called The Cajun
and the Korean that doesn't really uh
rhyme as a name but it describes both of
them I guess anyone but Bobby Gary White
said I love Bobby Lee he is my favorite
but I think Delia's pairing with Thea
would be better they have two episodes
of this past weekend that are hysterical
I think that Delia and Theo Von would be
a great match they even talked about the
endangered species podcast like we
already saw that could be something
maybe he looks into very scary I have
great chest here too oh wow and somebody
saw it the other day on a video and it
was like 70 people said something yeah
yeah yeah yeah at first it hurt my
feelings didn't remind me of my
grandfather well and that's kind of not
Bittersweet but also uh to have 70
people talking about your [ __ ] great
chess here that means you made it yeah
if you have 70 people talking about your
gray chest here you made it yeah yeah
but you're we're the same age
I know you are a couple months younger
than me I'm 39. I bet that's we would
say same age yeah in life yeah you
wouldn't be like no I'm a few months
older than you because that would be so
weird yeah like we're both 39 you
wouldn't be like no we're not the same
age my birthday's first yeah yeah well
we'll tell them how old you really are
you know it's just a couple days earlier
yeah oh that's like asking if somebody
told me by the way we lie you're 45 I'd
be like that makes a lot of sense
Theo and Bobby and then kalila and
Brendan can do one together where nobody
listens and they fade away Into
Obscurity that was actually the top
comment the top response on this poll so
I felt like I had to include that one
shop as a punishment even your best
friend Brendan Schaub you know people
online are like you know I mean do you
hate Brendan what's going on there or
there's like people attacking me because
of that little thing that I had on with
Brendan and then they you know at the
end of the day it's like I love Brendan
I love you I love everyone you know I
mean we just had a little conflict you
know what I mean but at the end of the
day I wouldn't change any of that for
the world you know even my breakup with
kalila it's like you know it's just a
part of life people said Schultz and
Theo have a better chemistry than any of
the others the podcast episodes they've
done together are some of the best ones
and I have to agree with that I honestly
don't think just from watching anyone
makes theovan laugh harder than when
he's paired up with Andrew Schultz it's
honestly a shame it's shocking that we
haven't seen theovan on flagrant yet
hopefully that's in the works sometime
soon so you're not going back bro you're
not going I'm going back
[ __ ] you bro this is a question turn the
question on right I can't even throw my
mind there's no sound coming out fix the
damn deal I couldn't even throw my bike
away because y'all made fun of me for
the way I laugh on the podcast
that is you
bro yeah that's you
who said that who did that one
I did that's awesome bro find a better
way to fix it Riley yeah I know that's
what I'm trying to do okay I was crying
Andrew and Theo always work really well
together and the jokes between them are
so good I'm not gonna lie I really liked
Andrew Schultz's appearances on this
past weekend they were entertaining
podcasts that's why I'm saying dude I
don't think anyone has entertainment
value that Schultz and Theo have
together like they bring out the best in
each other they're hilarious together
Loki if I was on this poll if I was
Voting I would have voted for Schultz I
think that would be a great podcast one
of the sleeper picks in this whole thing
was Shane Gillis A lot of people
commenting for shingles shangila
shangilis Matt and Shane so kind of a
three-person Vibe with Matt chain and
Theo this guy said just Matt so now we
have two votes for Shane one vote for
Matt and one vote for Matt and Shane
I feel like the guy in Survivor two
votes Matt one vote chain
the ghost of Norm Macdonald or just call
it this past weekend same studio with
Matt and Shane hosting I don't even know
if this guy includes Theo in this now we
just have Matt and Shane hosting this
past weekend
I guess I would watch that humor's a
risk like I always the thing that was
always funniest to me was
a telling a humor or being a doing a
humor when you
right when it's not supposed to be done
like the guy's a Little Caesars yeah
it's Taking Chances dude yeah yeah
taking a chance yeah the guy it took
they took a chance man they somewhere he
took a chance dude and they are probably
Legends amongst their friends they are
probably I truthfully yeah look never
put a swastika on a pizza right not
advocating that yeah they deserved to be
fired yes that's a good cancel yep
there's a good cancel there yeah because
it's dicey you're using product to push
your own agenda
but those dudes are probably funny yeah
there's no chance those dudes are not
funny yeah that's because they're not
real Nazis they're not right they were
real Nazis they're not putting swats
together on pizzas right they're doing
other work they understand how wildly
funny it is for somebody to open a pizza
box
and I holy [ __ ]
and here's the crazy they're willing to
risk their careers dude
it's so funny I'm sorry we're careers is
awesome
yeah but they're putting it on the line
they're all in that's a good point about
yo I'm risking my Little Caesar's job
this is gonna be funny it just blows off
it's basically like German roulette
Matthew Ortiz said Nate bargatsi this
seems like an obvious one honestly Naper
gotsi napargazi they both live in
Nashville they were Supply to this one
that said bad this would be a good Duo
but there's no way Theo could keep it as
clean as Naper gatsu would want for his
podcast
I think that that would be a great like
there's Nate is one of the best
stand-ups working right now one of the
best joke writers and Theo seems to do
really well with these people that
understand humor as a whole that pick up
on the small jokes that Theo always
loved to work into podcasting with
another comedian I would love to see
Nate on this past weekend or Theo on
nateland they're pretty good about
getting your bags out there now some
airports let's be honest and then we can
talk about the south because uh that's a
place where sometimes they're not New
Orleans you could wait a week and a half
for a bag they just don't even one guy
brought it one time they brought in no
joke it was like four days later dude
was no joke I swear to God that we
denied it had on one of the [ __ ]
shirts in my bag
he just took it out and wore it and he's
a tough guy yeah and I couldn't he took
it for a run I don't want to get a bat
with him about it yeah he's happy to
have the rest of my stuff yeah but some
airports in New Orleans I think it's and
he wore this shirt it takes 20 minutes
yeah I think he forgot he wore I think
he got a little cooked up and [ __ ]
forgot he wore it yeah and then just has
it on and it's like here's your bag you
know that's cool man and you just gotta
go like all right you know like yeah
because he's gonna be con uh
conversation like you'd have to hey
that's my shirt yeah I'm not getting
involved in that yes even though I would
love to get he'd love to see get
involved like just to see what he's
gonna say like because it's a guy like
that that could be like you say it and
he's like yeah yeah I do you know what
are you gonna do where are we gonna go
from here where do you want to go from
here yeah like how far do you want to
take this and then you just have to be
like all right I'm good I guess this is
as far as we take it you know unless you
want to just go at it I would love to
live like that guy I would love that
that I'm jealous of that guy that you
could put on someone's shirt
out of the luggage it's not yours
deliver it and and like I mean he's
rooting that you say at that point he's
probably like please say something yeah
but I'm going to do the most obvious
thing you know this is your shirt yeah I
hope it's like a real shirt that's like
it's not like you know just like a polo
that you're like you could argue right
it's something that's like oh yeah
straight up you it was like Vaughn
family reunion
this is your family the last sleeper
pick that I didn't even think of that a
lot of people commented Riff Raff Riff
Raff and it's not even close Tom segora
or riffraff which I don't know how Tom
Segura or riffraff like that's two
things that are interchangeable yeah
either Tom segora or Riff Raff they're
kind of the same the answer is obviously
Riff Raff they are the same person yes
Theo and Riff Raff are the same person
not Tom segora but yeah those are good
episodes Riff Raff would be fun they
definitely come up with a good name for
that Thea would probably have to get
permanent cornrows I'd watch that
podcast too I'd honestly watch all these
with Theo I think we're the only mullet
bearing
municipals yeah marsupials yeah bruh I
mean we definitely those [ __ ] hair
Bears you know we're up there yeah the
hair Bears the [ __ ] afghanistrans bro
we got that [ __ ] I got I got the damn
Florida follicle Fountain back yeah you
do man I like the podcast that he does
with random people that work in society
like the mortician episode Dusty sleigh
if you want to get Dusty slay podcast
you should check out the joke World
podcast featuring Dusty slay we'll link
it up right there to Stefano there are a
few votes for Stefano this has 23 likes
Chris Stefano and Theo Von always a good
time bring Lee from Joey Diaz podcast
plus do shrooms again so a permanent
podcast where they do shrooms every time
and it's Lee and Theo Von
that's probably the winner so far I
think that would have the most success
so far Lee and Theo have a great Vibe on
the church what's happening now and that
shroom episode is an all-time classic so
if they did that every time once a week
I don't know if it's sustainable but the
views for a few months they would be
[ __ ] through the roof the Obama what
is it baby I'm here man I'm freaking
here dude I'm trying to keep the devil
out of my system bro but he's here those
mushrooms are [ __ ] calling these [ __ ]
I'm feeling positive dude ate me a
little stem I think I made money to
another bro just to get Daddy
you know just to get the [ __ ] devil
off my necks little ones with a little
there you go huh something this little
torch this little baton let me put this
little black one that's the longest one
that's the longest one in the bag
that was the main one under the [ __ ] I'm
not even we're breaking out when it
happened don't you give him the worst
half what do you give a [ __ ] cheers bro
yeah cheers
come on Lee get your brain up man you
already Jesus Lee looks [ __ ] your head
is holding blood bro your head's holding
extra blood for your body Bill Cosby
that's honestly what a lot of people
probably were thinking for the other in
common I don't know why I didn't include
that in the poll that's kind of an
obvious One Duncan Trussell is
interesting I think that they would have
a really good vibe together it'd be kind
of a insightful you know
Duncan you know they're very like
compassionate people Comedians and
they're funny so I'd listen to that and
then this guy said Mark Norman that had
18 likes
that's obviously a good one to Louisiana
boys chopping it up always have good
this past weekend episodes honestly you
couldn't go wrong with any of these
people thank you for watching this video
if you had a good time today please
subscribe to joke World follow us on
Instagram we'll send you some free
stickers in the mail we're always
posting content on Instagram our second
Channel I guess there's a tick tock but
don't really worry about the tick tock
just mainly YouTube this main Channel it
would be dope if you all subscribed
hopefully Theo starts a new podcast soon
keep commenting on the community section
if you want your comment to be featured
in one of these videos
so that's it
that's it I'll see you Monday with
another common news update
[Music]
foreign
[Music]